[Music]
welcome everyone to a game analysis
session today and we have a couple of
games that we're gonna go over first
okay so first we're gonna start the game
play by Claudio
against Nick Carlo so let's see so okay
efore c6 first of all everyone here know
the name of this opening
caro-kann it's it's a very good opening
I think it's a very good quality opening
and if you're at a stage that you're not
sure what to do against efore and you
sort of thinking about maybe learning
and opening this is opening that I
highly recommend this is something what
I like to play myself and to you know I
play in tournaments it's still a
relatively new opening for me because I
played the French defense for over 20
years but last couple of years I start
playing some caro-kann and enjoy it it's
good opening so he played the knight c3
move and already a little bit of a
surprise because the main move is d4 d5
and here white chooses basically what to
do he has a few options here he can play
e5 this will be called advanced
foundation and he can take and play the
exchange and then play a pawn of attack
or maybe some other setup or you can
play Knight c3 Knight d2 this moves
basically lead to the same type of
position so it doesn't really matter
what he plays know where he goes with
this night because in that case you
still take so it doesn't really matter
he plays 92 or Knight c3 because after
you take he's gonna capture back anyway
and you play Bishop f5 ok so this is the
position so
but a white player played Knight c3 d5
is correct Knight f3 Bishop g4 yep
I've actually played a game recently in
Las Vegas North American Open and one of
the important rounds I had same exact
position against the International
Master from Canada so maybe in some
point I will show you while I'm next few
weeks I'm here I will show you maybe
this this game so Bishop g4 you always
want to get that Bishop out in caro-kann
the main difference between the French
defense and caro-kann in the French
defense you sometimes have that bad
bishop chopped in that you're trying to
get rid of but when you play the coral
Khan you normally don't have a problem
with that Bishop so that Bishop is
usually out so that's why you play the
Bishop g4 move here and activating the
bishop and also pinning this should be
too yeah this is already it's just a
move it's a normal move but after this
move white cannot fight for advantage
this is just the passive move after
which black can play is 690 f6 and get a
very nice in the comfortable position
the challenge here is h3 of course
because you kind of develop the bishop
bit too early so he is immediately
putting the question to the bishop and
now what would you do in this position
if you were playing this position with
black and your bishop is questioned you
have two options here right capture or
retreat capture that's what I did also I
capture also because this is also a move
but it's a bit of a risky move if you do
this then he can take on d5 you take
back he plays g4 you have to go back
here and looks a little bit dangerous
his knight is active he is threatening
to play Bishop b5 now he is starting to
play Bishop b5 check and pulling
pressure on this patient okay so there
have been some games played like this as
well but this is dangerous a little bit
dangerous so that's why the best thing
to do here when you're questioned you
just take
okay he takes III simply and then you go
Knight f6 you just develop your pieces
it's a roughly equal position no white
enjoys the pair of the bishop in this
position but on the other hand you know
he doesn't have a very good control of
the center and he still needs to develop
a lot of pieces so it's roughly equal
this position so Bishop g4 Bishop e2 his
plate and now II six is a good move
Castle Knight f6 after 96 is played
White has few options here he can push
the pawn on e5 but in that case we are
not afraid though we just go Knight F to
d7 okay and then we can try to play c5
and 96 good position so he takes this is
how the game developed Knight e5 Bishop
e2 g6 very good play so far
clock is playing very well white is not
playing very well it's it's black heads
of equalised this game very easily so at
this point actually if I had a choice
and somebody say okay here is the
position which color you want to play
with and I will take black here already
because black already actually more than
equalized here okay so 96 96 d4
and Bishop e7 is played so let me ask
you a question here when you had this
position you have two options right
where do we put the bishop here you play
Bishop e7 which is fine you may be
worried about Bishop g5 haha
aha yes yes I agree I agree there is
there is this pin what I like about
Bishop d6 is just more active actively
placed and he's not really threatening
anything here I mean yes there is a pin
but it's not like he's gonna do anything
there right now and he doesn't have any
way to put more pressure on the pinned
piece okay so he doesn't have a way to
put more pressure on that pin piece so
you can just castle okay
sure still I'm still not worried about
that yes make you swim moves when he
takes okay you take with the Quinn he
takes you take let's evaluate this
position spend a minute or two here
everybody should think little bit and
tell me who you think is better here
optically it seems like white is a much
better structure if you look at the pons
the formation but in reality who is
really better here white or black black
okay why why black is better okay we
have that half open file right half open
file okay what else what are the places
you can mention more pants in the center
that is excellent
that means black has a good control of
the center half open fire what else we
can mention here bishop on either sides
and uh-huh and we have a good bishop
here we actually as if we compare now
with the bishop and a knight which piece
is more active here that is controlling
more squares you see the scope for this
bishop look at the scope guarding a lot
and his Knight yes it's on c3 but can go
much can go too many squares here okay
okay okay
so anyway I wouldn't worry about this
Queen f3 Bishop f6 ayah we can actually
we will be happy if he does that and the
reason we go here there is a very strong
idea I want you to see here when he
plays the move b3 what is the best move
here for block what is the best move
here to try to get a little bit more
active
which one
which removed the Queen to a5 then he
can take one of six so it's could be a
little bit dangerous what you can do
here you can try to activate your rook
and play something like this route goes
to before now he plays a natural move to
protect it and now we have a backward
pawn here right upon that is a little
bit when you have a weakness what do you
try to do with that weakness well trade
it off right when you have the weak pawn
you want to get rid of that weak pawn
the weakness should be eliminated if you
have a chance and here look at this idea
you push and now look at that looks like
this is a loose piece here now
and if he takes of course you can just
take back with a Bishop on c5 and you
have a fine position here but you can
also consider something tactical like
this Bishop takes h2 check
he takes rook h4 check he goes back here
and Queen to c7 attacking here and also
threatening checkmate here so tactics
also work in favor for black okay so
that's why so keep this idea in mind
that when you have a route that can move
with the tempo we move that rook here
and it's on a half-open file putting
pressure on the pawn on b2 and we don't
stop we try to force b3 and then we go
up before okay so Bishop e7 is a fine
move Bishop d7 in my opinion is a little
bit better just a little bit better move
because it's a little bit more active so
Bishop e7 is played the rook d1 block
castle castle rook b8 correct and now h6
looks like played Bishop f4 yeah now
he's attacking the rook maybe it would
have been slightly better for you to
play h6 now so when he plays Bishop f4
it doesn't come with the tempo okay so
we just changed the move out a little
bit if you put the rook on b8 next one
he's got a bishop if you have that each
six in mind so you can maybe start with
this move first and then when he goes
back on H ordain you go rock PA okay
that's a possibility
because now Bishop goes to f4 it's a
pretty good bishop so Bishop d6 was
played to exchange Queen d6 and now
after Queen D takes d6 what is black
trying to do here if let's say somehow
white played this move HD
absolutely you wanna play c5 here yes
your he also understands that what
you're trying to do
yeah he's a pretty good player so he
sees that you wanna do
c5 he wanna get rid of your weakness
okay and that's why he's stopping it
okay you could have played c5 earlier if
you really wanted it but you wanted to
get more developed and then play it but
sometimes if you want to prepare
everything some you might not have the
time to do it so now he played Knight a
for Knight is on the rim but it's a
concrete idea to stop c5 so Knight a 497
plate Queen a6 I was trying to get a
little bit more active Queen c7 c4 yeah
so now he's active and he wants to play
rock a c1 looks like now he might be he
might be slightly better here okay
he might be very slightly better here
okay
okay so see for Quinn to be seven plate
exchanging the Queen's rook AC one Luke
FB 8 correct King F one King goes on a
fade Knight c5 Knight xe5 oh I guess CT
XD was played at some point okay some
some point this was played exchanged
already occurred 95 rook c5 okay 95 was
played then you took but then his rook
is coming to a good square on c5 so the
question is if there is anything else
that you can try to do here to stop his
rook from coming to see 595 was played
by black but the question is is that the
best move here can black do something
better here maybe of course it's easy to
just exchange but we have to make sure
when we make the exchange we don't allow
the opponent piece to get active and I
feel like he is getting a little bit
active here
[Music]
look to before there is a little problem
with that move huh
unfortunately the night is a tricky
piece here is the tricky piece and he
can try to afford you so well you're
close you're very close you because
you're fighting for some squares but you
have to just put that rope to a little
bit better square just a little better
square and should be fine little better
square for that rook
c7 could be played yeah
c7 could be played which is a fine move
then I think after this he will just
capture capture text X check taking goes
on b6 so this would have been fine for
you you know it's if he has two rooks
here it could be strong for him but if
it's one rook you can handle it but
another idea is look to b5 challenging
that night okay
trying to see now what is it going to do
just just challenging it okay
you know if he takes just King takes 90
xt7 King takes d7
now if for example a for just go back
and the thread now is to capture it and
win the pond on video nights but it's a
problem for him because beetrice week
okay so that's what you could have done
well you took the reason I don't like to
take too much because he gets to control
the C file yeah now you got the control
of the C file and I think you're
slightly worse now it went here and then
we don't have any more notation here but
you can tell us what happened here on a
seven yeah so he played here uh-huh f6
okay uh-huh okay but this is really the
slightly worse position for black bloc
already slightly worse here and who can
tell me the main reason why block is
worse here the main reason why block is
slightly worse yeah White has the
control of the C file and black rooks
are also doubled but unfortunately
they're not really it looks like they
are attacking but you can never take on
b3 so okay so that's why it's don't
necessarily wanna this basically the
rooks are placed better here on the C
file then the rooks on the B file okay
it was a pretty close game it was a
pretty close game blackest black came up
actually a little better out of the
opening it's just later on in the game
like for example here I think c5 should
have been played early did you think
about me playing c5 here early don't
wait too much yeah if I was playing
black-ish I think I would just go here
immediately put the question to the
bishop and say okay decide now what you
going to do with your bishop you're
gonna take on you're gonna go back so if
it takes then I think we are extremely
happy with the docks for Bishop so he
probably should go back here and then I
can play this move rook e8 without
worrying about that him he can Clovis
before attacking or another possibility
here is to play Queen a5 actually this
is probably the best move here for you
and next move is c5 no matter what
because you want to get rid of that pawn
so c5 is coming and you know black black
will be slightly better here and then
you have a great set up after c5 rook
fc8
rue kb8 like let's say he plays here you
go here take and then you go pressure
pressure and if you go something like
this night on the rim what can you do
here you need to do a double attack here
[Music]
excellent
going before double attack two pieces
you know this is not a very good idea to
have one piece on this side another
piece on the side double attack now he
has to take yeah he's not losing a piece
but he's in trouble
and now the night is hanging on a four
and if he plays b3 Bishop takes a 1 B 3
is losing the rock here so you cannot do
that and now black is clearly better so
that's what you have to do here in this
position play h6 first attacking the
bishop before you play rugby played h6
first attack the bishop bishop goes back
to h4 and a very strong move Queen a 5
activating the rook getting ready to put
the rook on b8 and c8 and play see if I
because after all the c6 pawn is a weak
pump
it's a backward pond right and when you
have a chance you want to exchange that
pawn this pawn is a weak pawn so we want
to play C 5 and we want to get rid of
that pond and then we have the open
lines for our rooks
because rooks they won't open files so
create those open files to have the
advantage this is advantage for black
yeah just just remember when you put
your rooks on b8 and see it here and
after c5 you have some nice pressure ok
sure sure okay the next game we have
here okay
okay Danielle and this was played or
displayed not a very recent game there
well okay then against I'm okay
great let's start okay you are block
excellent okay let's take a look
draw d4 d5 Knight f3 knight c6
interesting do you like to play the
chigorin defense aha so that's why I
asked that question because black is
playing knight c6 the chigorin defense
is C 496 yeah and who is the most famous
Grand Master who played this against
Gary Kasparov because this is considered
a little bit not a very you know main
type of opening a little bit a little
bit questionable I'm gonna say this
opening in general like when you play
very high level but this player very
unique player didn't afraid to try this
against Kasparov no young girl maybe he
did also but the game I remember was
more osowiec Russian Grandmaster
morisevic stylus against Kasparov and he
tries against some other players but
this is the type of opening that you
know it leads to unbalance type of
positions but your opponent played
Knight f3 and you went 96 Bishop f4
Knight f6 in this position Bishop g4
move makes sense for you to play that's
the reason you got your night out so you
can play Bishop g4 and put some pressure
[Music]
there's a pressure on g4 so if I was
playing this position probably the
natural continuation here for you would
be to try to get this Bishop on g4 and
put some pressure on that night now he
goes here
you could go 96 a little bit more
technical a little bit better is to play
east 6 then you can go Bishop d6 and
exchange his strong Bishop and if he
captures your back you can take back
with the Ponyland
so this is the easiest way for you to
equalize this game there are other ways
to play here but if you want just
equality and that's what you should do
with black when you play with a black
pieces equality is perfect in the
opening first equalize the game and then
try to aim to you know develop
initiative because normally with black
you can get a good position right away
if your opponent is playing really badly
in opening because you know even if he
makes the one or two small inaccuracies
that gives you a chance to equalize the
game only okay so so remember when the
night is on c6 Bishop g4 it's a chigorin
team to get that Bishop out there Knight
f6 was played III aha this next decision
I'm not liking it that much each six was
played from the first class it looks
like okay it's just a normal move right
but what is the problem with this move
why I say I didn't like it that much
what was that reason can you find that
reason why this could be a little bit
questionable this month
excellent you just drop your bishop so
for the I don't want to say who the rest
of the game but for a long time now
we're gonna be trying now to find a way
to get this Bishop out so what's the
best thing to do to avoid that what
could you do first and then play a 6-pin
it
remember pin it to win it so that's
right so you have to even though there
might be simple things here but in chess
even for strong players even the simple
stuff if that's what we do
you know when we play most of the time
it's just a simple idea so it's a pin
looks good go for it and then you play
six because not only when you block your
bishop you not only you have a bad piece
now on see it that piece is causing a
problem getting your root out because
it's going to be bothering us you know
between these pieces now so one bad move
in opening and suddenly for next maybe
20 moves you might not feel very
comfortable okay but if you play Bishop
c4 e6 Bishop d6 you're going to be
feeling very comfortable in this
position okay so everybody should
remember okay in this type of positions
you want to activate the bishop before
you lock in that bishop okay so remember
that see that's what he did that's why
you got this Bishop out he didn't want
to have the bishop so that's how you
lock in Bishop e5 Bishop e7 plate
okay all right I mean a little bit more
natural to go here first to unpin the
pin so and if he tries to play here this
is bad now you take and now it's got a
loose piece on the five okay so you're
not in that Hari to capsule right away
here because there are absolutely no
threat so it'll be slightly more
accurate to go here so you went 95
Bishop d7 takes takes castle a6 Bishop
went back you castle c4
if white manages to get the night out
bring a rock in he might be slightly
better here
okay okay c8 a3 rook f d8 before now
plate D takes e4 Bishop c4 wait a minute
Knight takes d4 Wow
excellent idea
very impressive and this idea works
because black player instead of worrying
about his development instead of getting
his Knight out here for some reason he's
still keeping the night here
he shouldn't keep the night here you
should get the knight on c3 this is a
move without thinking you play okay
because the piece is not developed and
we are already on move 12 and if that
piece is not developed the rook is not
gonna get developed so we need to get
those pieces out okay so that's why you
wanna play the move Knight c3 here he
played before actually my original idea
was to play e5 here I don't know if you
notice that move e5 is also winning upon
if I was also just the natural simple
move e5 and
he cannot take because if it takes you
take sorry
you take he takes you take okay
and then can do much but instead of E 5
you played 94 this might be even better
the point is if capture it's a little
bit of an unusual idea I have not seen
this kind of idea in a early opening
stage but basically there's just a lot
of loose pieces here for a moment and
now if take block just takes and here's
winning a bishop winning one of the
bishops so how did you find this move
it's just you just so the idea good good
for you Queen b3 was played yeah it's
too bad that you drew this game because
you played very nicely took on a four
now Bishop e6 is this doesn't work no
this doesn't work check King f8 you're
just off a piece here you're surely
winning here on the path to the victory
here all you got to do is just play a
little bit accurately but this is where
a lot of games sometimes are not won
when you get into a winning position you
sometimes relax you can never do that
you only relax when your opponent stops
the clock and resigns you can't relax
even you get a winning position I've
done it myself a few times and it's not
good g3 queenie 525
okay it's it's a fine move there is a
square that just looks so good for that
Queen here you know it's just like
entering into his position
absolutely absolutely Queen f3 now your
queen is so active here it's gonna be
very difficult for him to remove it from
- and on top of that you attack the
knight so he needs to protect this
Knight
so most likely he will play Rock a c1
and then you will play here rook on open
file because you want to kick that Queen
now he goes back on h3 and now the rook
is hanging here so we cannot
unfortunately lift our rook up here this
is a trick what that's it solvable I
just move the rock away now okay and now
we can go Bishop e5 next because your
queen is better than his even though you
wrap a piece you probably want to
exchange but first of all when you play
twenty five you won the exchange you
would go back but here your queen is too
active
I think he's gonna maybe play queen g2
and propose the exchange himself and
then you can exchange and just win the
game because of the extra piece okay
that's what you should do here okay
because Queen if I would have been a
good movie if you could force the
exchange but if you're not gonna
accomplish the force then you shouldn't
do it okay then you should go Queen f3
for sure
now Queen b3 was played of course white
doesn't want to exchange he knows he
will lose if he does that rook a d1 rook
cd8 rook d3 Queen h5 King G to Bishop e5
rook f3 okay not bad exchange Queen
takes c3 Queen f7 still completely
winning so I don't know what happened
later we'll get there check King g8 okay
this is just the winning position here
that's why I'm sort of moving fast black
is just upper piece and it's just let's
get to the moment where things started
to get a little bit out of control group
DB 8 that's what you play right not sure
if I like that decision because you have
a rook on an open file okay
so he doesn't have any threats here he
doesn't have any threats here what can
we do here well the idea I see here it's
again going back to playing simple chess
when you have a rukon open file what's
the first thing you need to look for
enter that look where that's it that's
all what you gotta do play it simple you
go rook to d2 and your rook is on a
second rack and now I'm not just gonna
be satisfied with that this rook is
coming also then it will be real power
on that second rack pulling pressure
you also have some Queen d5 type of
ideas as well here okay rook t2 is very
strong okay Queen b6 yeah this move
shouldn't do it very important to
remember do not deactivate the developed
piece unless it's absolutely necessary
okay so remember do not deactivate very
important that you don't do that because
if you do that then it could be some
problems that's the idea to remember
Group D seven is good if you worry about
that rook b8 so these are good but but
not don't want to go to b8 here okay
a 495 okay
tactic 27 you're back going here you
just need to find a way to exchange
pieces that's all
so Queen e2
26
why don't you just go Roque Phaeton just
yeah I feel like some some some moves
were played here that they weren't
really doing that much for you like in
this position his active pieces the
rukon F file right when opponent has an
active fish what do we do great that's
it so how can we trade here okay
if capture I just capture okay yeah if
you wants to go make sure go away but
then you have a pressure on that that
file so it's possible that you can try
to attack him if you move the way like
go Queen e1 or something okay so instead
of entering anywhere you just go rook F
it and you just exchange
okay so Queen e2 was played Queen six
Queen h4 Knight of 6 the afraid ok still
winning Brooke II 325 check King g1
Queen h5 if it takes here you have did
you see the move that you can do if you
had taken check with the Queen because
otherwise if you take back he takes the
Queen and if you take your screen he has
a in between check here but black has a
check here and after it comes up then
you just take okay so queen h5 he didn't
do that he played rookie 7
take take
look at seven rookie to cook a one a
five yeah again in this position you
just need to play simple like this rook
is the good piece here right so let's
try to trade that good piece here if you
just change one pair of the rooks it
just task will be so much easier so you
just go here instead of going after
pawns or anything you don't need any of
that you just go here rook F d7 and then
you have two ways to do it you could be
force exchange and start picking up
those pawns or you can also go rook T to
an exchange once you exchange one of the
rooks you will win this easily because
then you wouldn't have any type of
contra
yeah yeah this rookie one wasn't
necessary okay a five and now c5 was
played rock takes e5 Roxy 497 take
Knight f6
and just need to exchange that rook I
know just go here and just start
attacking him on that second but anyway
I just I just don't know how you did not
win this one okay okay we lose we don't
have anymore notation but tell us what
happened here you might have just hung
the piece huh you have you know a great
game and you know the victory seems like
in the bag you know and then suddenly
some things happen but I think at this
point it's pretty clear that black could
win so today we'll learn that you know
when you're winning you don't relax okay
remember game is not all until he stops
the clock reaches the hand that's when
the game is really over I myself had
games but I was completely winning you
know seven pawn advantage I mean it
really winning but then I end up making
some inaccuracies okay so very important
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]